at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking when I ask you a personal
question
magnetic organisms living facility this
episode is brought to you by bowl and
branch which is what I have on my bed at
home in San Francisco I use myself and
there's a lot of nonsense in the bedding
business for instance thread-count not a
measure of quality total myth Egyptian
cotton well guess what it's a plant
called Gus if you bought by day and say
I don't think that's how you say it but
that is how I read it generally not even
grown in Egypt and the made in Italy
label that you're so proud of well you
know you shouldn't necessarily pay extra
for that because it often means that
it's just finished in Italy and woven in
places like China the general industry
markup for bedding is 700 to 800 percent
at the usual retail stores you would go
to Boleyn branch which is bol L is
incredibly high quality they have a
higher cost of goods than many products
you might buy at 3 to 4 X their prices
because they sell direct consumer so
check it out go to bowl and branch calm
that's bol L a nd b ra n CH calm bowl
and branch calm and not that you need to
but you can try anything you order at
home for 30 days if you don't love it
send it back and you get a full refund
go to Boleyn branch calm and use promo
code Tim for 20% off your entire order
whether that sheets towels blankets
duvet covers anything and shipping is
always free let's check it out ball and
ranch calm promo code Tim
this episode is brought to you by XO
protein it's one of the startups that I
work with I love what they do these guys
are making protein bars using cricket
protein powder and before you screw your
face up and look disgusted I bet they
taste better than any protein bar you've
ever had before I devoured these bars
after lifting sessions I take them with
me on the road the recipes were
developed by a three Michelin star chef
former head of R&D at the Fat Duck which
was ranked the number one restaurant in
the world during his tenure the bars are
paleo friendly no gluten no grains no
soy no dairy etc they are high in
protein and flavor and extremely unique
and they do not pop your glycemic
response up oddly enough and you can
look that up on line to see some stories
on that Ferren Stein that's the
journalist who looked at it on top of
all that they are less processed than
nearly all protein bars you'll be able
to find this is your chance to see what
the hype is about the founders were just
on the Forbes 30 under 30 list and they
are offering a deep discount to Tim
Ferriss show listeners if you go to XO
protein com forward slash Tim that's EXO
protein com forward slash Tim today you
can try a sampler pack with all of their
most popular flavors for less than ten
bucks
that's EXO protein com forward slash Tim
and I would recommend doing it
relatively fast and that's not abs
scarcity thing there start up with
limited inventory and they sell out all
the time that is what happened last time
I mentioned them so check it out EXO
protein com forward slash Tim
greetings ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show this is a
shorter episode instead of a long format
interview with an expert of some type
and we're gonna focus on Seneca my
favorite stoic thinker and author Seneca
the younger his writing that I'm gonna
highlight an excerpt is roughly 2,000
years old yet it is timeless and we are
going to listen to you on the shortness
of life this is an essay that I revisit
at least once a quarter along with all
of his other letters that you can listen
to if you would like through the Tao of
Seneca at audible.com forward slash
Tim's books and this particular letter I
will highlight my favorite portion which
begins with quote why do you torment
yourself and lose weight over some
problem dot dot dot and on it goes this
is a fantastic reminder to mind the
critical few to ignore the trivial many
and much much more I hope you enjoy it
letter 49 on the shortness of life a man
is indeed lazy and careless my dear Luke
Ilyas if he is reminded of a friend only
by seeing some landscape which stirs the
memory and yet there are times when the
old familiar haunts stir up a sense of
loss that has been stored away in the
soul not bringing back dead memories but
rousing them from their dormant state
just as the sight of lost friends
favorite slave or his cloak or his house
renews the mourners grief even though it
has been softened by time now lo and
behold Campania and especially Naples in
your beloved Pompeii struck me when I
viewed them with a wonderfully fresh
sense of longing for you you stand in
full view before my eyes I am on the
point of parting from you I see you
choking down your tears and resisting
without success the emotions that well
up at the very moment when you try to
check them I seem to have lost you but a
moment to go for what is not but a
moment ago when one begins to use the
memory it was but a moment ago that I
sat as a lad in the school of the
philosopher sodium but a moment ago that
I began to plead in the courts but a
moment ago that I lost the desire to
plead but a moment ago that I lost the
ability infinitely Swift is the flight
of time as those see more clearly who
are looking backwards for when we are
intent on the present we do not notice
it so gentle is the passage of times
headlong flight do you ask the reason
for this all past time is in the same
place it all presents the same aspect to
us it lies together
everything slips into the same abyss
besides an event which in its entirety
is of brief compass cannot contain long
intervals the time which we spend in
living is but a point nay even less than
a point but this point of time
infinitesimal as it is nature has marked
by making it seem outwardly of longer
duration she has taken one portion
thereof and made it infancy another
childhood another youth another the
gradual slope so to speak from youth to
old age and old age itself is still
another how many steps for how short a
climb it was but a moment ago that I saw
you off on your journey and yet this
moment ago mix up a goodly share of our
existence which is so brief we should
reflect that it will soon come to an end
all together in other years time did not
seem to me to go so swiftly now it seems
fast beyond belief perhaps because I
feel that the finish line is moving
closer to me or it may be that I have
begun to take heed and reckon up my
losses for this reason I am all the more
angry that some men claim the major
portion of this time for superfluous
things time which no matter how
carefully it is guarded cannot suffice
even for necessary things Cicero
declared that if the number of his days
were doubled he should not have the time
to read the lyric poets and you may rate
the dialectician x' in the same class
but they are foolish in a more
melancholy way the lyric poets are
avowedly frivolous but the dialectician
x' believe that they are themselves
engaged upon serious business I do not
deny that one must cast a glance at
dialectic but it ought to be a mere
glance a sort of greeting from the
threshold merely that one may not be
deceived or judged these pursuits to
contain any hidden matters of great
worth
why do you torment yourself and lose
weight over some problem which it is
more clever to have scorned than to
solve when a soldier is undisturbed and
traveling at his ease he can hunt for
trifles along his way but when the enemy
is closing in on the rear and a command
is given to quicken the pace necessity
makes him throw away everything which he
picked up in moments of peace and
leisure I have no time to investigate
disputed inflections of words or to try
my cunning upon them
behold the gathering clans the fast shut
gates and weapons wetted ready for the
war
I need a stout heart to hear without
flinching this din of battle which
sounds roundabout and all would rightly
think me mad if when gray beards and
women were heaping up rocks for the
fortifications when the armor clad
youths inside the gates were awaiting or
even demanding the order for a Sally
when the spears of the foeman were
quivering in our gates and the very
ground was rocking with mines and
subterranean passages I say they would
rightly think me mad if I were to sit
idle putting such pretty posers as this
what you have not lost you have but you
have not lost any horns therefore you
have horns or other tricks constructed
after the model of this piece of sheer
silliness and yet I may well seem in
your eyes no less mad if I spend my
energies on that sort of thing for even
now I am in a state of siege and yet in
the former case it would be merely a
peril from the outside that threatened
me and a wall that sundered me from the
foe as it is now death-dealing perils
are in my very presence I have no time
for such nonsense
a mighty undertaking is on my hands what
am I to do
death is on my trail and life is
fleeting away teach me something with
which to face these troubles bring it to
pass that I shall cease trying to escape
from death and that life may cease to
escape from me give me courage to meet
hardships make me calm in the face of
the unavoidable relax the streetand
limits of the time which has allotted me
show me that the good in life does not
depend upon life's length but upon the
youths we make of it all so that it is
possible or rather usual for a man who
has lived long to have lived too little
say to me when I lie down to sleep you
may not wake again and when I return you
may never go
forth again you are mistaken if you
think that only on an ocean voyage there
is a very slight space between life and
death
no the distance between is just as
narrow everywhere it is not everywhere
that death shows himself so near at hand
yet everywhere he is as near at hand rid
me of these shadowy terrors then you
will more easily deliver to me the
instruction for which I have prepared
myself at our birth nature made us
teachable and gave us reason not perfect
but capable of being perfected disgust
for me justice Duty thrift and that
twofold purity both the purity which
abstains from another's person and that
which takes care of one's own self if he
will only refuse to lead me along by
paths
I shall more easily reach the goal at
which I am aiming for as the tragic poet
says the language of truth is simple we
should not therefore make that language
intricate since there is nothing less
fitting for a soul of great endeavor
than such crafty cleverness farewell
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by XO
protein it's one of the startups that I
work with I love what they do
these guys are making protein bars using
cricket protein powder and before you
screw your face up and look disgusted I
bet they taste better than any protein
bar you've ever had before I devoured
these bars after lifting sessions I take
them with me on the road the recipes
were developed by a three Michelin star
chef former head of R&D at the Fat Duck
which was ranked the number one
restaurant in the world during his
tenure bars were paleo friendly no
gluten no grains no soy no dairy etc
they are high in protein and flavor and
extremely unique and they do not pop
your glycemic response up oddly enough
and you can look that up on line uh to
see some stories on that Ferren Stein
now that's the journalist who looked at
it on top of all that they are less
processed than nearly all protein bars
you'll be able to find this is your
chance to see what the hype is about the
founders were just upon the Forbes 30
under 30 list and they are offering a
deep discount to Tim Ferriss show
listeners if you go to XO protein combo
/ Tim that's EXO protein calm old / Tim
today you can try a sampler pack with
all of their most popular flavors for
less
ten bucks that's XO protein calm
forward-slash Tim and I would recommend
doing it relatively fast and that's not
a BS scarcity thing they're startup with
limited inventory and they sell out all
the time that is what happened last time
I mentioned them so check it out
XO protein comm forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by bowl and
branch which is what I have on my bed at
home in San Francisco I use myself and
there's a lot of nonsense in the bedding
business for instance thread count
not a measure of quality total myth
Egyptian cotton well guess what it's a
plant called Gus CPU bottom I didn't say
I don't think that's how you said but
that is how I read it
generally not even grown in Egypt and
the made in Italy label that you're so
proud of well you know you shouldn't
necessarily pay extra for that because
it often means that it's just finished
in Italy and woven in places like China
the general industry markup for bedding
is 700 to 800 percent at the usual
retail stores you would go to Boleyn
branch which is bol L is incredibly
high-quality they have a higher cost of
goods than many products you might buy
at three to four X their prices because
they sell direct consumer so check it
out go to bowl and branch calm that's
bol L a and DB ra n CH calm Boleyn
branch calm and not that you'd need to
but you can try anything you order at
home for 30 days if you don't love it
send it back and get a full refund go to
bowl of ranch calm and use promo code
Tim for 20% off your entire order
whether that sheets towels blankets
duvet covers anything and shipping is
always free check it out fold ranch calm
promo code Tim and until next time thank
you for listening